If you're an alcoholic, you
should know that drinking too much is poisonous. If you keep drinking it chronically, you'll lose
weight, and if you take too much at once, it
can even lead to death. I heard that one of my friends, Toseki,
incited him to drink a lot.  If that's the case,
then you'll die.But I don't think Takashi-dono died from drinking too much because he was a strong
drinker.It's said that the dead man was a daring man with a good personality who
drank all the alcohol left behind from Toseki.
But the turtle
turned over and spilled all of what the drunkard was drinking.So,
if the turtle had poison in it, we
wouldn't know.That's right.  Or, I
wish I could just be needlessly sparkling
as usual, but these days, people seem to be much more child-like than before, and there's an
unavoidable mix of sweetness and saltiness,
adding saltiness to the already sweet sake.  It has a
strange taste. It's sweet, right? It's just the
taste of an elderly
man. He has a huge sweet tooth, and no matter how high-quality smoked meat or rock salt he prepares, he won't touch it.
In the past, it used to be spicy.  I used to like it, but one day I suddenly felt like I didn't want to
eat it anymore.I've become diabetic to the point where I can't taste the sweetness of most of the meals I've said before.I don't want to bring my memories back to reality.I don't feel like drinking any more.  Did you
get any salt? Oh, I hear they served rock salt, moonbeans,
and dried meat. Should I prepare the same thing?
No, I'll finish drinking it before that, so no. In that
sense, I can get the turtle that the old man was drinking.  It's
broken and broken into pieces, but I
don't care.
Besides, there's one thing I'd like you to look into.
[Music]